ma question s'adresse au ministre de
l'intérieur de tous nos territoires
s'élèvent les appels au secours de nos
concitoyens qui ne parviennent pas à
obtenir dans un délai raisonnable des
documents d'identité rien que dans ma
circonscription de seine-et-marne c'est
une trentaine de familles qui m'ont
saisi alors que les demandes ont été
enregistrées en mairie en mars aucun
titre n'ont été reçues à ce jour des
familles vont devoir annuler leurs
vacances fruit de l'epargne d'une année
les frais de leurs billets non
remboursables or ont été exposées en
vain dans un pays comme le nôtre où la
dépense publique atteint presque 60% du
pib' ce sont des dysfonctionnements
inacceptables
alors que l'émission de titres sécurisés
est de la compétence exclusive de l'état
c'est semer les germes de la rancoeur
public contre un état obèse et
impuissant c'est faire le lit des
populismes pour des français qui ne
veulent qu'une chose qu'avec leurs
impôts l'état fonctionne le 4 mai un
plan d'urgence a été annoncé à ce jour
les collectivités locales auquel la
charge de l'enregistrement a été
transférée font ce qu'elles peuvent pour
remédier à l'engorgement en amont mais
en aval les délais de moeurs mais
question sont donc simples quelles
mesures correctrices vont être apportés
si des traitements en urgence sont
prévus pour quelques cas particuliers
prévoyez vous des mesures
d'indemnisation pour ceux dont les
billets les séjours ne pourraient être
remboursés nous sommes dans le cadre
juridique du plein contentieux mais on
n'en sait la lourdeur ne serait-il pas
opportun de prévoir un processus
d'indemnisation simplifié à la hauteur
du préjudice matériel et humain c'est
l'efficacité de l'action de l'état que
questionne cette question des documents
d'identité